oh my god that's disgusting well Gregg's
is already won cuz it's from Craig's
this wins I can't swear can I
that's disgusting what is that hey
what's up lab Bible it is time on in
here and I'm going to play slack Wars
while I'm writing British snacks over
American snacks so let's go oh these
aren't alcoholic drinks are they oh it
is root beer oh my god that's disgusting
what is root beer now I know I mean that
tastes really good actually this is
death juice this is essentially what
this is kids be wary because you can
drink a lot of it but you will die
amazingly it's gonna have to be this
disgusting blue drink I don't think I'm
responsible enough to have the power of
time which is what I'd want I think I
would just mess up everything so I
probably go with the power of being able
to control water that'll probably be my
power okay here we go
ah okay here we go just licorice is that
what you call this is this the English
one come on yeah all right disgusting
I'm not going on this pin here that is
disgusting I can't swear can i that's
[ __ ] disgusting
I used to love toxic waste you ever have
so many toxic waste that you can't eat
anything for about three days after that
you've burned your mouth off correct
English thank you all right really
bitter poison X
oh the toxic waste was earlier but no
next much sweating Wow I don't it's
between medium spice sometimes and hot
and depending on the day and how long I
want to spend on the toilet but medium
spice really
half-chicken period food chips pizza
bread olives balm string I'm actually
gonna go for now notes tonight now ah
well Greg's is already one cuz it's from
Craig's well that's a Krispy Kreme
doughnut though isn't it that's good I
like that
motor sausage roll well I know what a
such a broad tastes like lads this wins
I used to order great everyday when I
was when I was at secondary school there
was one outside one bus stop then I used
to have the ice buns every day
[Music]
I don't really like cheese and that much
I'm not really that much of a fan of
cheese let's definitely skip that one I
always wonder who was the first person
that went yeah I'll just try that bit of
moldy cheese who was the first person
that thought that was all right you know
okay okay
is this what um Woody Harrelson eats in
that zombie film but I've always wanted
to try one of these if this is bad I'm
gonna be so disappointed
bite a bit damp though if you kept this
Oh Alex minging nope
what is that bathroom
sänger all of the jaffa cake if your
land doesn't offer you jaffa cake just
leaves in your nan I mean defecate for
me jaffa cakes again win that one for me
unfortunately the British tanks well
unfortunately no fortunately the British
tanks
I just sell British that's allowing them
I just have them all imported over
Thank You lab Bible for having me it's
been fun and congratulations to Britain
on winning the snack Wars challenge